today the dallas police department  arrested officer brian reiser  badge number 9586 and charged him with  two counts of capital murder  this criminal investigation dates back  to 2017  with the death of two unrelated murder  victims we received information through  a witness  that implicated riser in both murders  we will not allow anyone to tarnish this  badge  as we all know the actions of a few  affect the many  i we have committed to you in taking the  criminal element off of the streets of  the city of dallas  to perform relentless follow-up on  anyone who does harm to this city  and that includes within the walls of  this police department